oh man I got pants on
I just coming through strong today very
strong hi guys my name is grace Helbig
if you did not know now you know your
life is different now let's distract
ourselves from everything in life that
is absolutely awful and try to make our
lives somewhat easier here are pool
noodle life hacks ways to make your life
easier using those foam pool noodles
some people call them swimming wieners
scare ways you might not know you can
use a pool noodle to make your life
easier
okay big chatter now but
okay
there you go
there were a bunch of ways to use a pool
noodle to make life easier Astra's
different for yourself thank you for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to its youtube channel
because we're all just trying to do
stuff and by we're all I mean I'm trying
very very hard to get you to enjoy my
company in a digital way on a sporadic
but sort of regular basis
I'm not consistent or reliable which is
why I think we would make great friends
and that's it hope you're treating
yourself and others as well as you
possibly possibly can
yeah yeah